it seemed that the foundation was all
but rid of scp-682 after an unlikely
glitch in reality sent the hard to
destroy reptile deep into a limitless
interdimensional Abyss known simply as
the back rooms this meant that the
standard reality also known as the front
rooms was safe from one of the most
dangerous monsters in existence but that
didn't mean the anomaly was neutralized
scp-682 had been slowly but surely
making its way through every level of
the back rooms and taking out its
aggression on any living thing that
crossed its path well except for Jerry
there was something about the entity
which resembled blue hyacinth macaw that
had made it tolerable to scp-682 which
was rare for the reptile as it
infamously regarded most other life
forms as disgusting and worthy only to
be destroyed Jerry had been frightened
Away by an encounter with the archers of
level 10 and ever since
scp-682 had been looked the little guy
this search eventually led the creature
to backtrack through the suburbs of
level 9 and enter level 11. the
presumably infinite City this was the
largest settlement that scp-682 had seen
in the back rooms and whether or not it
found its avian companion it was eager
to cause some Havoc among the locals and
speaking of the locals what a sorry
sight they were countless facelings were
acting like ordinary humans going about
their day strolling down the sidewalks
and entering buildings seemingly with no
reason other than to humor the themed
environment a few of the facelings were
even walking hounds on leashes in a
grotesque pantomime of a dog walker 682
was infuriated somehow in its seemingly
infinite ways of causing the creature
distress the back rooms had managed to
combine the two things that annoyed it
most the so-called civilized creatures
of its native reality and the equally
disgusting and entities that dwelled
within the back rooms unable to stand to
look at this any longer
scp-682 went on a violent Rampage
attacking every entity in sight its
previous subjective of seeking Jerry no
longer mattered to it as the anomalies
discussed for every part of this
alternate reality overwhelmed all of its
thoughts if 682 found itself starring in
Pixar's Inside Out All the emotions in
its mind would be variations of disgust
as the body started to pile up
scp-682 began to sense something in the
airwaves of this level it soon adapted a
long-range radio antenna in order to
better pick up the frequency the voice
on the other was calm and sounded like a
middle-aged human male you're listening
to radio back rooms the voice said if
you're just tuning in now welcome to
talking with Ralph I'm your host Ralph
there you are
scp-682 said triangulating the radio
signal with internal senses this Ralph
character was going to be next to die
well he would be next if nothing else
with a dumb look about it got in the way
and in the back rooms the chances were
high that a new pathetic creature for
scp-682 to destroy would be around every
corner either way 682 marked the new
Waypoint on its mental map and started
to zero in on Ralph's location looks
like we got ourselves a brand new entity
in level 11 Ralph's voice echoed in
scp-682 skull I'll be giving away a free
time slot to whichever faction bags the
Beast Within the next 12 hours
scp-682 realized almost immediately that
it must have been the new entity that
Ralph was referring to it was familiar
with the idea of factions within the
back rooms because of its previous
encounters with the major explorers
group but now the situation threatened
to get interesting maybe there would be
some factions here with actual combat
training on par with the mobile task
forces could these new factions pose a
challenge to such a powerful ketter
class anomaly 682 heard the buzzing of
tiny propellers overhead and saw a group
of surveillance drones flying towards it
with cat-like agility it leaped into the
air and swatted the drones with its
Limbs and Claws the cheap hunks of
carbon fiber were shattered easily
halfway across the city several members
of the Drone surveillance Squad were
throwing their headsets on the ground in
frustration with one faction having
missed its chance the next was quick to
arrive five cool teens on bikes and
skateboards rolled up to the end of the
street they were all dressed in 80s
fashion for some reason check it out
that's one righteous reptile said one of
the teens gnarly said another 682
cringed even with its limited
understanding of human culture it could
tell that 80s Nostalgia was overplayed
and that the era of 90s and 2000s
Nostalgia would soon arrive and what
better way to hasten it than getting
these troubled teens off the street just
don't ask where they went after that
another so-called faction down an
scp-682 was already feeling uncontested
so far these humans were even less
intimidating than the entities this was
a bit mind-boggling to scp-682
considering that the foundation was made
up of humans and they had managed to bag
several much scarier anomalies than
anything in the back rooms naturally
scp-682 included itself among that
number the Radio Studio we're talking
with Ralph was broadcasting from was
getting ever closer taking a slight
detour the reptile tore straight through
level 11's Meg base of operations once
again the Explorers within proved to be
no match for the creature it emerged on
the other side of the building back into
the city streets and was immediately
confronted with several new explorers
these humans weren't exactly 80s
fashionable opting instead for tactical
gear and long black cloaks they had a
haunted look about them and each carried
a mighty spear sinner they shouted in
unison the eyes of Argos are upon you
scp-682 pounced and made short work of
them but paused warily when it noticed
the presence of a slightly taller
humanoid that had been standing behind
the group it was dressed the same as the
humans but it had an aura of Mythic Fury
the humanoid had no eyes but somehow
scp-682 could feel itself being watched
as if from all places at once it was
unsettling for the creature as it felt
like being back at the foundation
contained in a vatic acid while a
science lab full of researchers watched
and judged yes judged that was the
feeling and scp-682 knew it all too well
the humanoid stepped forward brandishing
its spear what was it with this place
and Spears
scp-682 wondered the powerful entity it
had on level 7 had also wielded the
spear was that weapon meant to be some
indication that this one was just as
tough I am all seeing Argos and I have
seen that your sins are innumerable said
the humanoid entity Argos lunged forward
thrusting with its spear towards scp-682
the reptile received the brunt of the
strike and was launched backward without
even giving 682 time to recover Argos
thrust its spear through the creature
pinning it to the concrete Sinners must
be punished Argos bellowed pushing the
spear deeper into the reptile's body
scp-682 struck back with a bite but to
its surprise Argo seemed to have an
impossibly high tolerance for pain and
its wounds seemed to be healing almost
as soon as they opened this told 682
that close range attacks wouldn't get
this entity spear out of its back it
needed to get the freaky humanoid out of
spear range and then hit back with a
reach weapon of its own
tapping once again into the radio
frequencies 682 levied a blast of
concussive Sonic energy from its body
while this didn't damage Argos it did
achieve the intended effect of knocking
The Entity a few feet back
scp-682 used this chance to get a bit of
distance and readied its next weapon its
own reptilian Tale Now elongated and
equipped with a sharp blade at the end
in terms of reach as cp682's tail whip
outclassed argos's spear the battle was
on now 682 swung its powerful blade in
an attempt to cut through the enemy's
weapon but it seemed that the spear had
the same regenerative abilities as its
wielder you're not human
scp-682 taunted Argos you're even more
disgusting you are a sinner Argos
replied regeneration was one of scp-682
strong suits too and the spear wounds
that Argos had given it had already
recovered using the bladed whip of its
tail as p682 kept Argos and his spear
out of Close Quarters it continued to
slash The Entity but the wounds were
healing too quickly to leave an
impression Argos was also skilled enough
with his spear that he began to deflect
the Whip and Advance towards 682 it was
time to try something crazy so crazy it
just might work Argo stopped in his
tracks as suddenly
scp-682 was nowhere to be found the
reptile had become effectively invisible
and this was because it had adapted to
counter argos's true Vision now encased
in a ghostly Aura of sin cloaking energy
scp-682 maneuvered around Argos and
prepared to finish it off if you're like
me then this won't bring you down but it
will hurt Argos and I will enjoy it
calling upon the memories of the acid
Vats back at the foundation
scp-682 secreted a powerful acid across
its entire body and left onto our is
back the thing about Spears is while
they are ideal for engaging the opponent
at a distance they were far less useful
if that same opponent was grappling your
limbs with his weapon rendered unusable
Argos was now locked in a battle of
endurance with scp-682 it had generated
the most powerful acid it could generate
potent enough to even cause a bit of
damage to itself it's over Argos
scp-682 chuckled you may be good at
fighting but only one of us has spent
years being contained within a caustic
prison you lose
scp-682 held down Argos for as long as
it took for the acid to fully immobilize
him the entity had struggled to break
free but 682 was able to continually
grow strong enough to tighten its grip
but the boss of this level destroyed
scp-682 continued towards the radio
tower
um
congratulations you Ralph said over the
radio your win lizard man how about you
and I have a nice peaceful chat not
having any of this
scp-682 beamed its own words into the
radio station along the same frequency
tell me how to get to the next level and
I'll consider sparing you but only
because you're that worthless haha I
Dare You Lizard Man Ralph responded
nervously Ralph directed scp-682 to a
specific window inside of one of the
nearby skyscrapers when scp-682 opened
this window it was immediately
transported into a cramped white room
with a table that had a single chair
nearby this was level 12
scp-682 was most assuredly going back
for Ralph later yet another level seemed
specifically created to play on the on
you way of The Human Condition which was
something that 682 still had no frame of
reference for humans were afraid of the
stupidest things 682 thought to itself
it waited in this white room for what
felt like several hours until it was
eventually no clipped back into level
11.
scp-682 roared loud enough to shatter
the glass windows on several buildings
in the infinite City it charged out of
the skyscraper and onto the roof of a
nearby apartment building which just so
happened to be another surface with no
clip capabilities 682 never got to hear
a response back from the talk radio host
before it fell several stories down into
another level of the back rooms entirely
level 13 an apartment building that
while not technically infinite was
presumed to have a very high number of
floors the hallways were more cramped
than the hotel on level 5 so scp-682
shrunk itself a bit to avoid getting
stuck they gritted its teeth and
prepared for the usual routine three two
one a clump a female moth and a Hound
came slinking down the hallway like a
random encounter in a jrpg
scp-682 hated these backrooms entities
so very much and could barely fathom why
they could stand each other it seemed
that no matter what level these hostile
entities appeared the Goon Squad only
ever attacked creatures that weren't
native to the back rooms without further
deliberation 682 ran the Three Stooges
over trampling them with its Superior
Powers it was more than done taking
small fry seriously and that included
Curly Larry and Moe as it wandered
through the Halls
scp-682 started to hear the droning easy
listening music which pervaded this
entire level it was the sort of sound
that humans used in elevators and
grocery stores places where the DOL
mundanity of life was meant to serve as
a comfort and yet it seemed to be the
soundtrack of the back room's latest
hellish level in a way 682 started to
feel pity for the humans trapped here
not because their suffering was a bad
thing from its perspective but because
of the fragility of their finite psyches
if whatever forces that created the back
rooms did intended to be a realm that
tormented humans the humans were
definitely making it too easy and if
humans themselves made this to contain
other humans the implications were even
sillier when the very structures that
humans built to shelter themselves from
the elements apartment buildings cities
towns were able to cause this much fear
in them it was a sure sign that Humanity
was always doomed to retreat screaming
back into the Wilderness after centuries
of learning nothing from its Collective
delusion of civilization or at least
they would be doomed to that fate if
they weren't already doomed to be wiped
out by scp-682 just like every entity in
the back rooms 682 wouldn't rest until
every last faceling Clump death moth
death rat Smiler Hound dollar burster
and any other ridiculous entity that
dared to crawl through these wretched
corridors was personally sent to its end
it got so pumped up thinking about this
that it didn't even notice itself no
clipping again thousands of floors
rushed by in the blink of a moment until
the reptile finally dropped through the
lobby of the apartment building a new
level unlocked just like that
scp-682 regained its bearings on a
forest floor covered in a vibrant
Crimson grass the trees had pitched
black bark almost blending in with the
Knight itself the sky above was a
glistening sea of Bright Stars this was
level 14 known to most explorers as
Paradise this level had a strange power
which supposedly made the Explorer happy
and feeling as though they belonged
however much like the darkness within
the suburbs level 14's
happiness-inducing atmosphere would have
the opposite effect on the hard to
destroy reptile it hated this Forest
even more than any previous level of the
back rooms and wanted out immediately
from experience 682 knew that poking
around would eventually result in it
finding the entrance to the next level
so it hightailed its way through the
trees it needed to find that exit
desperately as it ran through the woods
682 could hear howling somewhere far in
the distance and it didn't sound like a
pack of wild animals disturbingly it
sounded like a crowd of humans
attempting noises similar to wolves but
they were committing so much to the
performance that it almost seemed like
they truly believed they were wolves
whatever hippie dippy nonsense was going
on here wasn't
scp-682's concern right now it was
burning with so much contempt for level
14 that it could barely think straight
its feet crashed through a field of pale
white bones lying just beneath the grass
but it kept on running they collided
with 3 Downing it in a second but it
just kept running the howling ceased in
the distance and still scp-682 continued
to run as fast and as far as it could
then Against All Odds the creature's own
mind began to turn against it as the
effect of level 14 continued to take
hold you don't belong anywhere you are a
mistake of nature
scp-682 could recognize its own voice
echoing in its head and for the first
time it was terrified of itself you are
a thing that cannot ever be happy this
paradise will never accept you nowhere
will ever accept you you are disgusting
scp-682 froze in its tracks there was no
exit from this place the back rooms had
won the sick game it was playing with
the reptile's existence it would be
trapped here forever in this inverted
Paradise for humans a self-loathing
Immortal without any hope of Escape it
was so paralyzed by the immense disgust
that it felt for itself that it almost
didn't notice a speck of blue amongst
all the red the blue on the feathers of
a hyacinth macaw Jerry
scp-682 said aloud don't follow him you
are a monster you will never know
companionship or love shut up you
disgusting creature
scp-682 growled back at its own mind
shakely it began to move its legs in the
direction of Jerry The bird-like Entity
was the only thing that still felt real
about level 14. everything practically
faded away into a churning ocean of red
and black it took every ounce of
willpower that SCP 682 had but it kept
moving towards Jerry you are the most
disgusting monster to ever exist the
foundation should have destroyed you the
back rooms will destroy you you don't
belong in this world
scp-682 did everything it could to shut
out the voice even as Jerry took off and
flew deeper into the Crimson forests of
level 14 without even realizing 682 had
grown a pair of blue wings of its own it
followed Jerry through the trees and
then higher toward the Starry Sky one
thought cut all the negativity that had
been swirling through as
cp-682's mind it doesn't matter if I
don't belong anywhere else Jerry is all
I need a light Shone down from above and
suddenly it was as if level 14 itself
was rejecting
scp-682 while the reptile was focused on
Jerry a piece of the sky seemed to
glitch and then as if it were a solid
piece of Machinery it fell down toward
the red grass below behind the Fallen
chunk of sky was a metallic hallway not
unlike some of those back at the
foundation Jerry flew through the
opening and scp-682 followed with its
own macaw-like feathered wings a shift
in gravity much like the event on level
7 occurred and 682 soon found itself
standing inside of a long silvery
Corridor having come through a hole in
the ceiling goodbye level 14 hello level
15 the futuristic hallways oh yeah the
future rules here we are in the future
and it's right it was certainly a lot
less of a personal nightmare to scp-682
Jerry had clearly flown ahead but 682
knew somewhere deep down that it
wouldn't have made it here without him
if the reptile had any respect for the
concept of fairness it'd probably
considered the debt for Jerry fleeing in
level 10 to be repaid but its empathy
wasn't quite so sophisticated that it
could wave favors like that so it's
soldiered on looking to catch up with
Jerry for no particular reason at least
as far as it knew the hallways were
definitely man-made in appearance but
from a time so technologically advanced
that even the foundation couldn't dream
of it the best part about level 15 was
that it was filled with what appeared to
be human remains most of these corpses
were marked with knife and gunshot
wounds perhaps the result of some kind
of Mass Slaughter either way it was
clear that all these humans had been
dead for a long time the only good human
is a dead human
scp-682 news to itself it seemed that
the future did in fact kind of rule
because From scp-682's perspective level
15 was populated entirely by quote good
humans there was still no sign of Jerry
but there were also no annoying entities
to waste the reptile's time compared to
level 14 the futurist call ways were the
real Paradise while it was as far away
as ever from feeling any kind of
authentic contentment
scp-682 decided that this place was
acceptable no life no Foundation I'm
starting to like it here now go check
out could scp-682 be contained in the
back rooms at scp-682 Slaughters through
the back rooms for more of the hard to
destroy lizard wrecking this liminal
hell